Mẹ người ăn tu nhập bà mê làm trị một tháng vẫn tay trắng vì đối bà được con, sẽ bằng chi phía ai cũng tróan.
Chưa bao giờ em đã mốt khi ra những chi tiêu của gia đình có lẽ vì vậy mà em không tích kiếm được gên nào.
Em xin từ vẫn về cách về nguyện, chứ bố mấy hai tuổi rồi mà vô sản.
Này là những sống chia sẻ của một bà mẹ ở gên ăn, tuo hút sự trủy và trang lột.
Được biết, su thu nhập hẳn tháng không thấp, hẳn bà mê làm trịu, in chỉ vẫn không tích gửi được.
Nhìn bà nịch kê chỉ phi mở bà mẹ này đưa ra có thể thấy phân chi nhiều nhất là tiến học cho bà được con.
Chông đó với con đả nhỏ đã có bấm nóng mà mẹ này chỉ một chữ tiến học phi,
tâm trong nguyện động tiến học vẽ tâm trong nguyện động tiến học bán,
nâm trong nguyện động tiến học tiến việc, một phê nâm chữ tiến học tiến anh,
ngoài ra tên ăn luo hết sau trong năm nay gên đồng.
Với con thứ 2, tiến học thiến toàn tâm trong nguyện đồng,
tiến học thiến anh tâm trong nguyện động, tiến chung tâm trong nguyện động,
ăn sáng sáo trong miền động, con thứ 3 tiến học vẽ 2 chữ đồng một tháng,
tiến anh sáng luo sáng tiêu vật 1 phía tâm chữ đồng,
tính thêm cấp chỉ vì chúng cơ, tiến anh, còn ảo vui trời,
tổng vữ tiến chỉ phải chi trả ăn tháng là 2 mẹ sáo chữ đồng.
Với vân chiến chữ còn giư sau khi chữ các khoản, bà mẹ này cho biết,
một chận còn uống là hết ngày, con học máy định thoại hai máy viết tính là cũng sông nay.
Với thân mong bà, tết lễ biểu chá mẹ,
bản thân con kai ống, chưa phải đi vay là con máy làm rồi.